hey guys some of you asked me to make a
video on good hair care tips so i
thought all right i can do this video
request but the best way that i can
probably bring you value is to make a
video about the top 10 hair care myths
that most men still believe
so check out the full video to see if
there are any of these bad myths that
you still believe in that's actually
causing you to have bad hair let's not
waste any more time let's get to it
[Music]
now just very quick if it's the first
time that you're here my name is daniel
and welcome to dlm men's lifestyle
i'm gonna ask you to subscribe here and
if you don't really want to subscribe
then well just subscribe anyway
alright let's get into the top 10 hair
care myths that most men still believe
in
[Music]
some people believe that you can heal
your split ends with good hair care
products
is that true
of course not i just believe it because
of false product advertising it's just
no don't believe it if you have medium
to long hair and get split ends it's
better to just trim it
cutting or trimming your hair will make
it grow faster
that's false guys your hair grows from
its roots not from the ends of your hair
so trimming your hair will not make your
hair grow faster
but if you do want your hair to grow
faster also your beard then i've added a
good video for you in the video
description that you can check out
there's also some good products as well
so did you know that drying your hair
with a normal towel is a lot better than
a blow dryer blow dryer is actually very
dangerous for you
you probably heard that before right is
it true no of course not it's just
dangerous if you put it
on a high heat you know but if you put
it on the lowest heat setting it's it's
good and then it also depends on how
long you exposed your hair to water
because research shows that exposing
your hair to water for too long while
using an air dryer can actually be bad
for your hair because the interior of
your hair swells
[Music]
some people say that
if you wash your hair with the same
shampoo and conditioner your hair gets
used to them so you shouldn't change to
other products too quickly
that's just false your hair won't
suddenly get damaged just because you
use another shampoo and a conditioner
well unless it's a really bad product
but
no
if you find products that are better for
your hair then just use it
[Music]
another big myth is that dry scalp
causes dandruff
it's not true it's actually the opposite
dandruff is actually caused by oily and
dirty hair which makes your scalp oily
and dirty so if you don't wash your hair
enough you can get dandruff so if you
use products like
pomade wax gel hairspray and you don't
wash it
you can get dandruff so you gotta wash
your hair guys
if you struggle with bad dandruff check
out the video description i've got some
information for you
brushing your hair for a long period of
time is actually very good for your hair
no it's not it can't damage your hair if
you do it for too long because you
damage the hair's outer protective layer
now you've probably heard this from your
mom or your grandmom but if you get a
gray hair you pluck it out there's going
to be two or three that's going to grow
in each place
of course not this is just a funny myth
that's been taught from one generation
to the other
it's just a sign that you're getting old
man
i'm getting gray hair as well and if i
get one or two gray hairs then i know
all right i'm gonna get more because i
am getting older
[Music]
a lot of people still believe that hair
products are the main cause for a lot of
men going bold losing their hair
is not true it's a myth the fact is
your dna nutrition and stress mostly
determines if your hair will fall out or
not
now of course there are bad products
that you should stay away from that can
contribute to it if you don't wash it if
you don't treat your hair really well
but there are good products that's good
for your hair check out the video
description i've added a good list for
you
don't wear a hat
if you wear a hat too often you're going
to get bold
false it's not true there's no
scientific evidence that backs it up
for some reason some guys believe that
our bodies are made in this special way
that if we do not wash and clean our own
hair our bodies will do it for us
[Music]
that's just crazy and it's lazy as well
it doesn't do that in this world this
temporary world it works this way
everything goes downhill we need to
build things we need to keep things
clean
if you don't clean things it's gonna get
dirty don't be lazy you gotta wash your
hair at least two to three times a week
now just a bonus tip or some bonus
interesting information have you ever
heard people saying that you gotta clean
your hair because otherwise you're gonna
get lice
and it's interesting because lice
don't wanna live in dirty hair they like
clean hair
yeah turns out lice are more like us
humans we don't like dirty things
all right guys if you want more grooming
tips and self-improvement tips and watch
these playlists here and i'll see you
there and before you go
always remember life
is short so don't waste yours cheers
guys